uh talking about how to make leap to
Quantum cities okay uh
so hello good morning um so this talk I
started off with the comic and then ate
the title and then made the talk so
um so I'm not gonna claim today to prove
anything
um I just want to give some intuitions
as to
how um last year anurag anshu Nico
Brookman who are at Harvard in Bristol
respectively and I how we proved uh the
nlts conjecture and maybe how one should
move forward towards the proof of
quantum pcps
so my goals are very simple uh I want to
give a small recap
how to think about nlts
um it's very light it's not it's not
based on codes really it's just some
very simple pictures and then say what I
think are next steps
okay so the preface I mean if you're
unfamiliar with the quantum PSP
conjecture the the setup is quite simple
we're interested in hamiltonians uh
defined by local interactions you know
uh and in particular we'll be interested
in hamiltonians whose local interactions
don't specifically fit on a lattice but
you know the first thing we always think
about is hamiltonians that fit on a
lattice
uh and
the hamiltonians are very simple they're
say like K local interactions and the K
local interactions they're described by
you know two to the case as matrices
um and for any hamiltonian you can think
of it as an interaction on all the
particles uh just by you know the tensor
product structure
and then the whole hamiltonian is just
the sum of these interactions and we
want to understand properties of this uh
large Matrix there's a large Matrix but
there's not that many of them because
you know they have this succinct
description because you can describe
each of the local terms hi right so
they're a special class of large
matrices
and what we're really interested in is
just figuring out what the low energy
States look like and energy just means
eigenvalue so we just want to understand
some simple properties of what the low
energy set of uh of states for this
hamiltonian are and even maybe what that
energy is
so the famous result is that it is qma
hard to calculate this value up to some
inverse polynomial Precision
um uh you know you can make this like N
squared or I think or n Cube based on
uh you know exactly how you do the
reduction where n is the number of
particles
okay so you might say okay what's hard
to do this then what do you do next well
you say okay how hard is it to
approximate and there's sort of two
regimes so we know that the minimum
eigenvalue maybe it sits here
a product getting anything below a small
polynomial above that is going to be qma
hard and then somewhere up here at some
constant past the uh Epsilon times n
path the minimum eigenvalue it's NP hard
to find that and the rationale for this
is that you know the classical PCP
theorem proves hardness for classical
hamiltonians and that's a natural
subclass so we know that approximation
is NP hard to sum Epsilon
and what the quantum PCP conjecture says
it's hard to get past some other Epsilon
maybe they're not exactly the same but
there is some other constant Epsilon
Prime for which finding a ground state
below that energy is going to be uh to
make hard
okay uh so how would you go about
proving this well you could try to do
the classical PCP route you know you
might say where um we follow every step
one after another but the big issue that
comes the way is that there's the no
cloning there
so if you think about denur's 2007 proof
of the PCP theorem it really came down
to three steps one was this notion of
pre-processing where she took the
constraint problem here you could think
of it having an interaction graph like
through coloring and she made sure that
it was expanding and then whenever there
was a variable that occurred with high
uh in many of the Clauses she instead
took that one variable and replaced it
with a cloud of variables and then she
connected those Cloud by uh just
consistency checks making sure they have
the same value
and there's this step of Gap
amplification where instead of each
vertex in the constraint describing
itself it sort of describes its
neighborhood it says not only what what
color it is assigned but what color each
of its neighbors is assigned what color
you know two doors down
Etc and you have it describe its
constant sized neighborhood and now the
consistency check is a little bit easier
to do because now you can check that
whenever
two vertices uh describe the same point
as in so there's a point that's in there
the intersection of their neighborhoods
you can check consistency between that
and this step actually shows that it
this uh this problem is has a higher
unsatisfiability so it's amplifying the
gap
okay but now each vertex is describing
you know this neighborhood and that's a
little problematic because the alphabet
has grown really big each the variables
are acting on uh
you know the coloring it's like this
tensor product
so she does this she applies error
correction to reduce the alphabet and
again there's this component where she
has to replace High locality variables
with this cloud
and then you repeat this log many times
and you get the amplification for the
classical PCB theorem
okay but the problem is that many of
these steps violate the no cloning
theorem um although some of them can be
avoided you know principally these ones
in red all violate the no cloning
theorem in fact I'll say that this other
step of applying error correction to
reduce the alphabet is also not trivial
um but somehow there's going to be this
inherent tension between uh no cloning
and trying to do this uh PCP
amplification
so maybe this was too hard let's let's
step back
so let's see if there's another way to
tackle this or maybe even to refute this
problem
and to do that we have to say one thing
about State complexity so you know uh
Tony had a great talk earlier
um describing State complexity where
morally it was this very simple idea
that you know there's this decision
complexity class of it could be saying
something like does c accept any Quantum
State and there's an analog State
complexity class which is now instead
asking to build the quantum State itself
so both of these situations you could
ask about um
you know an object C in one case you
want the binary answer in the other case
you want the state uh which matches said
description
okay so how does this date complexity
you know paradigm
uh connect to the quantum PCP picture
well to do that let's define a notion of
State NP
um I don't I don't know if this is the
right notion but something I Define
which you could just think of it as a
set of classical representations of
quantum States so the idea is what do
you need out of this classical
representation it's given the
representation xn it's supposed to
morally represent some states cyan
and the requirement is you want to be
able to calculate
um the trace of O cyan for any local
observable o just from the classical
representation there should be a
polynomial time algorithm classical that
lets you calculate that uh
um expectation what's a local observable
one that acts on constantly many qubits
yes okay yeah so local observable
anything that acts on constant many
qubits so here's some simple examples of
things that could be in state NP one
could be like the description of a
constant depth circuit if you have a
constant circuit you can always uh
calculate this on a classical computer
because you can you only have to check a
limited constant size like cone
other things that might be useful is
like the description of a matrix product
State once you have a matrix product
State you can you know
close the tensor
or another option that's sort of a
little bit more esoteric maybe is to
list all the stabilizers for some
stabilizer state if you list all the
stabilizers you can actually calculate
this for any local observable
okay here's some examples which aren't
so the simplest would be just a list
claiming to describe a map something
that says okay when when you tell me the
Oracle o here's what the value is or uh
and this is because it's hard to check
right whether all those local
observables actually correspond to some
state so if there was a state underlying
it you might have just you know come up
with answers that were correct locally
but they you know don't there's nothing
consistent
the second one that's probably a little
bit more relevant that a lot of people
thought about is the notion of like a
classical Shadow it's hard to check if a
classical Shadow actually corresponds to
a state so
okay so how does this connect to the
quantum PCB conjecture so
[Music]
right exactly so you want to be able to
check that there's a bona fide state so
in the case of for example uh when we
have the constant depth circuit well you
have a circuit that generates the state
so the state is well defined right
you don't need to know what the state is
you don't need to be able to write it
down but
just do you need to know the existence
of one right
yeah so that would be another reasonable
example so if you give anything where
you can calculate the traces on with
respect to local observables
and you prove that you know it is a
state and you're good
yeah when you say it's hard to check
whether it is to stay corresponding to
classical Shadows is it providely hard
or is it just we don't know how to do it
yet okay so the five second intuition is
you know this classical Shadow is this
introduced by um
Robert pong and prescal and we're
getting there thank you thank you
um and it was this idea that you know
you take these you represent the state
by some Hallows that you've measured out
but the problem that you get is the
representation is not necessarily A
positive Matrix so it has Trace one
um and it's permission but you're not
sure it's positive in general I think
when you generate the classical Shadow
it doesn't generate a positive Matrix so
it doesn't actually you know ever it
doesn't really
uh represent a state by itself
you have to believe that it came
honestly
okay so how does State mp play in here
well this idea is that we're here which
conjecture to be qma complete so let's
imagine that their status state right
there which was in state NP
okay so that means you can describe
everything about it you can calculate
the trace of O cyan for no matter what
local observable and it what that uh
morally means right is that you can
actually calculate the energy
of the state with respect to the local
hamiltonian and you can calculate that
exactly so if such a state existed those
in state NP then it would imply that you
know qma equals NP so morally if you
believe this Quantum PCB conjecture it's
actually saying something very strong
about State complexity lower bounds
you could write this more generally
sorry what puts this indicate yeah so
imagine there was a state that had uh
low energy below this Epsilon threshold
and it was always describable in state
NP
then instead of providing the
description of the quantum State you
provide just the description xn and then
a classical device can use xn to
calculate the hamiltonian's energy and
because it's in state NP you know he's
promised that a Bonafide State exists
okay sorry you need such a state for any
Hamilton just
yeah just the one Hamilton one such
thing
yeah
so the same
thing yeah
um but surprisingly hard to disprove
um
yeah exactly you want the for every
hamiltonian below this Epsilon threshold
if there exists in a state entity
continues of this conversation
okay
I guess one could Define a state qcma
and
the education will also hold that and
[Music]
so if you have a Quantum PC injector and
you take any class below qcm that you
can pick whichever one's your favorite
is going to imply some State c lower
bound
for the appropriate definition of
State C for whatever that is you know
so what this does is this is a very
simple way of extracting a minimum State
complexity hardness
from the underlying Quantum PHP
conductor you pull out everything about
computation you're just saying I have to
have these objects which have such State
lower bounds and in particular when C
equals NP the quantum PCP conjecture
implies State NP lower bounds for all
types of State NP but including any
specific class of State NP and the one
that gave the community a lot of
interest was this one that was called
the nlts or no low energy trivial States
conjecture
um of their local hamiltonian system so
that all the low energy states require
at least a strong circuit depth lower
bound
thank you
um
okay so this we were able to prove last
year at about this time uh in June and
we showed that there's an explicit local
hamiltonian system so that every low
energy State requires uh High circuit
depth sorry um
we've been a resolution of the quantum
PCP conjecture that was just agnostic on
the qma versus qcma question yeah yeah
okay so then it wouldn't have to prove
the state complexity lower bounds in
that case right yeah yeah it's right you
require a conditional uh right okay
expectation okay fine yeah so you could
prove the upon a piece to be lower bound
yeah and not disappointment got it got
it
okay
so there is this is based on a sequence
of partial results and you know they're
saying something about how robust
entanglement morally exists at you know
low temperatures
um but it was really based deeply on
Quantum error correction uh specifically
High rate and high distance uh codes and
my goal for today is I want to say a
little bit about why that was inherent
and why that was the sort of the right
way to prove the first example of nlts
but maybe it was the wrong way to prove
the second example of nlts why we need
to do something a little bit different
in order to you know learn something a
bit more
okay
um so you know what should we try to
solve next
there's two things which I think are
somewhat reasonable one is you can try
to go and say well you know you you set
out this thing that there are stronger
State complexity lower bounds I need to
prove State NP lower bounds for
everything I need to prove State M A or
state qcma lower bounds right very
reasonable things I'll say a little bit
about this
um but what I think is actually
interesting is to go some other way
and I want to think about how do we
reintroduce computational hardness into
the problem so the nlts was great
because we know we extracted all the
computational tasks out of it it was
just about creating a hamiltonian with
certain properties
but you know in the end of the day if
you want to prove the quantum PCP you're
going to somehow have to put that
hardness back into the problem right so
we need to somehow figure out a way to
do this so the two main suggestions I
have is one is you could try to prove
that Quantum pcps are m a hard and you
know and there's a little tension there
there's this paper by Alex Grillo and
dorit about how
um you know a Quantum PCP for Ma you
know a roadblock that you have to avoid
you have to go around stochasticity
somehow
um but even before you try to prove that
Quantum pcps are ma hard I ask you can
you even prove their bqp hard
excuse me um yeah bqp heart are actually
even BPP hard now if you ask about BPP
hardness you have to make sure that
you're talking about
non-randomized reductions right
um but what I think I'd really like to
talk to you about is is there a way we
can construct local hamiltonians which
simultaneously are all nlts
and they're NP hard so it's hard to
uncalculate the minimum
eigenvalue but simultaneously all the
objects that we're going to ever
consider all satisfy this nlts property
and I'll say I think why this is you
know
um
but to do that to come around to this
question of simultaneous nlts nnp I need
to go through a little bit of how we
proved nlts the first time
okay so what's the simple proof sketch
well you need a method for proving
circuit depth lower bounds LTS is all
about showing that the low energy states
cannot be generated by short circuits so
somehow somewhere in there you have
circuit depth lower bounds okay so
here's the simple fact that's very
useful to know which is that for every
depth T circuit
there is a local hamiltonian
which is 2 to the T local and has a
unique ground state of C applied to that
state and the spectral Gap is one it's a
very simple hamiltonian you just take
the hamiltonian which just checks that
your state you know is all zeros
and you know apply c on it
okay
and you can prove this one very easily
the only hard part that you need to do
is prove the two to the T locality right
the spectral Gap in the unique ground
state just occur because you rotated a
known hamiltonian by a unitary
but the depth may be not intuitive but
you do this by induction so initially
you know you have it and then as you
apply a layer of gates you show that the
locality only goes multiplicatively by
size two
okay so when you think about load app
States you should always be thinking
about this hamiltonian which captures
that state
okay
then you need a second result and the
second one is this sort of interesting
point that let's say you have a set of
points X1 through XM
okay uh they're in the Boolean hypercube
and you have the property that the
distance between any two points is at
least L for some constant l then the any
state which is supported on X1 through
XM any state that it cannot be the
unique ground state of an L local
hamiltonian
this is the second big idea it's very
simple to prove
so here's the idea is okay PSI was this
way with this uh coefficients Alpha J
let me just take X1 the first one and
let me flip the coefficient on X1
okay and now let me compute the energy
so to compute the energy of PSI with
respect to any hamiltonian I just need
to add up all the energies at the local
terms right think about any L local term
h
and what you're going to get
is that this first line is just the
expansion of the computation nothing
fancy but the second line I have forced
J to equal J Prime
and the reason that is is precisely
because of the Assumption I have the 2 x
i and XJ you know they differ by L so
because they differ by L the only terms
of these that are non-zero in this
summation have to be those that J equals
J Prime so you get to remove it
and now you get that Alpha J squared
right
um
and now you can say that that has to be
the same energy as PSI Prime
because notice that you know if the same
thing would have occurred except you
then minus sign you would have gotten
two minus signs inside this absolute so
nothing occurs
so what it really says is something even
stronger which is that if you had a
state
which was uh of energy you know
something with respect to such a
hamiltonian if you added phases uh
nothing would change the energy would
stay the same do you want a plus sign on
the top and the definition of PSI Prime
absolutely yeah yeah there's a plus
sorry thank you
um
so you put that corollary back with the
with our we combine these two facts
right one that if you are a low depth
State you are the unique ground state of
a local hamiltonian you get you combine
this directly and you get that any state
which has such a property is not the
output of a load up circuit
there's a picture you should think about
which is that you have a set of points
you know where the distance between them
is all Ella Park
but I'll claim that it's not much harder
to show The Following extension which is
instead of just specific points X1
through XM I think about some subsets of
points S1 through SM
where I have again that the distance
between the pairwise distance between
these sets is something large
and then it says that if you have a
state which is again supported on these
sets
um
uh so that you know the the vector VJ is
just restricted to the J said then this
is not the output of a logged up circuit
either
and this is some distribution which we
call in our paper a well spread
distribution
and in fact this is a it's a nice
starting result which says you know that
any state which is exactly supported on
these subsets
cannot be the logged uh the output of a
short circuit but it's not a robust
result but I claim that it's actually
not that much harder to even make it
robust you can make it to this very
simple setting where you have two sets
S1 S2 even and the distance between them
is L and as long as they put mu Mass
uh on either of them you get a circuit
lower bound of the following form so L
as long as the larger L is the stronger
the lower bound The more mass you know
the strongly lower band but there's this
pesky uh one over n term and that's
actually coming from robustification due
to shabby Chef potential meals that we
don't know exactly how to remove
okay but at least I should convince you
that this is a good technique for
proving lower bounds is finding well
spread distributions
it seems like a good way of doing it and
this the reason why these lower bounds
exist is they're completely information
theoretic it's just about how fast can
information be propagated it's not
saying anything much more complicated
than that
but the unfortunate problem is that this
is really the only way we know how to
prove lower bounds for Quantum States
explicit ones there's specific other
examples and Counting arguments that get
you other lower bounds but if you want
it explicit this is morally the only
really robust technique and you need a
robust technique because we have to
prove lower bounds for all low energy
states so whatever lower bound technique
it should be amenable to small
perturbations right
exhibitions on the state on the state
and in the energy space actually but
okay so how do you find a well-spread
distribution well there's one natural
one that's always hiding around whenever
you think about error correction even
classical error correction because you
think about classical error correction
in my mind it always just looks like a
set of points whose distance is far if
the code is good right the distance
between 92 points and this is a very
good way of viewing the Exact Solutions
but uh you could ask you know what if
the low energy State look like what
happens when you say I don't necessarily
just want to satisfy my linear equations
but I want to satisfy 99 of my linear
equations
then what you get is that if the Matrix
you know that describes the code you
know really corresponds to some small
set expander you get the following well
first of all you're going to get these
kind of bubbling out around each of the
code words because any of those things
will be a small
perturbation of code so it's only going
to change on a on the checks that you
know detect that area but the second
thing that sort of interesting is you
get these additional sort of bubbles
that occur
far away but the property being that if
you're small set expanding you get that
the distance between any of these uh
bubbles any of these regions still
scales uh with the distance of the code
um
and so you get sort of this picture that
you know it looks exactly well spread
right it's got everything we need so we
say okay well this seems great we're
going to prove lower rounds because we
have well spread distributions and they
arise very naturally from codes and that
seems to be our only technique for
proving lower bounds
but here's the problem
which is that if there exists a low
energy State PSI which is supported only
on these purple regions or you know you
could you could go to like it has most
of its support on them but then what you
get is there has to exist a state Phi
with the exact same energy but that is
only supported on exactly one of those
purple regions
and the argument is exactly the same as
we did before you know I have the same
argument written down one more time
except now all I ask you to realize is
that the linear combination of PSI and
PSI Prime where I added that phase
right is just going to be the vector VJ
um
right sorry this should be PSI minus PSI
Prime excuse me but if you take PSI
minus I prime the only terms that will
remain are the terms in the V1 direction
right
so since and since one was arbitrary you
can prove this for any of the regions
so you hit this sort of annoying but
inherent uh predicament which is that
if you find a state side that's well
spread and then you even happen to go
around and you find a local hamiltonian
which had size a ground state
then you inherently will always find
these states Phi which are only
supported on one region but they're also
ground States right and and the same
would occur with low energy
um but then what do you get you have the
problem is how do you prove that Phi is
well spread because the whole well
spreadness was in this specific uh you
know basis and you saw but now it's
incredibly clustered so what are you
going to do
okay so the on the Saving Grace is that
there's sort of two measurements you
could take so if you have a state PSI we
were talking about what the Z
measurement distribution looked like but
we could also talk about the X
measurement distribution look like right
and the simple idea is that whenever the
state's measurement in one basis is
rather certain then the measurement in
the opposite basis is rather uncertain
right so if you're very uh concentrated
in one picture you're very
unconcentrated the other picture and you
can formalize this by some very simple
calculations you know you can put this
as like a homework problem in like
the first Quantum Computing class to
show that whatever Mass if you put a lot
of mass
on S in the Z picture
then consequently
on the small T's you can't be putting
very much
but still this doesn't answer anything
because all this says is that if I'm
highly concentrated like the state Phi
would be in the Z picture I need to show
that the X picture of the same state is
disjoint right that it could look like
one contiguous blob
but I need to show that in the X picture
it's well spread and that doesn't seem
immediately clear
but to provide some intuition for you
here we should look at the Torah code so
in the Torah code when you measure in
either basis you get this idea where you
get that there are four regions and they
correspond to four different types of
measurements so the first type of
measurement corresponds to
non-to-trivial Loops right if you
measure you'll get out some trivial Loop
another set corresponds to any Loop
anything which is topologically
equivalent to one of the logical loops
and then the other two are just you know
the other loop plus the linear
combination of the other two Loops you
get these four different regions and
it's not hard to argue that the distance
between these regions between
non-trivial loops and you know any of
these is
uh like uh scales like square root n
and what you get is actually I claim
that you'll see exactly
uh what I was telling you in the last
time which is that these Loops actually
correspond to four different states
right if you think about the Torah code
and we think about the standard x and z
operators that we write down on the
Torah code the set of if you were if you
had the state that was logical zero zero
the only measurements you'd get are of
this type
logical zero one you'd only get
measurements of this type Etc
right but that's in that's in one of the
two pictures but when you take the other
picture right if you look at the
hadamard picture then 0 0 uh it's
hadamar transforms plus plus so if you
have if you're completely concentrated
on diagrams and of this type in one of
the pictures you're extremely well
spread on all the diagrams as I said so
the the sort of the symphony that occurs
in it uh Quantum error correction is
sort of the right picture to get this
well spreadness in both of them
yep
so what we want is we want to do this
exact same thing we want to show that
low energy states when they're measured
in the Z basis or the X basis they're
well spread the key word is or we can't
hope to get well spreadness in both
faces
okay and here's where something that
bothered me a long time and when we when
I gave this talk on the virtual seminar
Matt Hastings asked you know why is high
rate necessary why was the rate a big
part of it the reason the rate was there
was it helps prove that these uh bubbles
are small the higher the rate the
smaller the size of the bubble which
means that when it's concentrated and
the more it's concentrated in one basis
the less it's concentrated the other and
that playoff was really necessary
distance was needed because you needed
to prove robust well spread lower rounds
you needed to prove that you know these
kind of things spread out and the
expansion was needed to show that when
you look at the low energy solutions if
they don't fall in a specific cluster
you know they move to another cluster
but clusters are well designed
um
it's an open question
of whether this expansion is you know
explicitly necessary whether you need to
explicitly assume it
um in the classical case you can prove
that whenever your code has high rate
and high distance it is necessarily
expanding but we have yet to be able to
you know complete that argument in the
quantum setting all right what does
expansion mean that the constraint graph
defining the code is
yeah exactly the I mean the the code
itself the CX and CZ codes themselves
will not be good expanders right because
uh you know like the Torah code is an
example they're terrible codes right
right but like the modulo
the CX mod CZ
there's an ex notion of expansion that
has three in there
um there's actually a very nice talk
three weeks ago when the uh in the
Boolean hypercube program by uh Hopkins
about this object and why he really
thinks it should be called small set
expansion
uh just that like it clusters well oh
okay
um
so let me get back to what I wanted to
say which is let's talk about how to
create local hamiltonians which might
simultaneously be nlts and NP yes here
some of how you're saying okay aircraft
can hold their fundamental foreign
[Music]
it looks a little away from codes okay
and I'll try to motivate that
so our construction was a stabilizer
Hamilton but you know stabilizer
Hamilton if they're not very
computationally interesting because when
all the terms commute you actually know
the minimum eigenvalue it's always going
to be zero
um and in general you know they're easy
to analyze
so the question is can we construct some
hamiltonians so that it is nlts that's
requirement one and the second
requirement is that it's going to be
hard to decide the minimum eigenvalue at
least NP hard
foreign
so here was a first idea which is you
could say well let me just sort of
encode my NP problem so let me try to
think of any my favorite NP problem it's
some CSP see I'm going to construct a
hamiltonian whose ground state looks
like this it's just this uniform
superposition over Solutions
um but then it looks exactly like the
same picture we had before which means
that unless the hamiltonian was highly
local where L is the distance between
the solutions then every X is a ground
state
this hamiltonian and morally what you're
getting back to is that your hamiltonian
is just the classical hamiltonian for
the CSP since it's accepting every
solution all by itself right so you
weren't able to add this quantumness
directly
so this doesn't work
um there's a very nice proposal that
came uh from two results one was by
anurag anshu and Nico which was the
precursor to our nlts result and the
other one was by anshuts
um
her name is
Kiani
um
and it says that well let's take us yes
CSP and let's explicitly route down a
hamiltonian whose ground state no longer
is just supported on those Solutions is
Now supported everywhere but there's a
decay
and the Decay is proportional to how
unsatisfiable that string is so for
every string X based on how
unsatisfiable is there's a Delta decay
and for Delta being you know constant
you can get a hamiltonian whose Spectrum
with each local term is bounded
so really what you get is sort of you
get this following picture where you
sort of have this probability
distribution that Peaks at the points
but then sort of decays out
right
and then what you get though is that
this hamiltonian if you measure this
hamiltonian you're never going to
actually get a solution
those occur with very small probability
but what you'll get with the decent
probability is you'll get something
which is close to a solution so if you
instead of thought of your uh constraint
as just a classical thing but it was had
some sort of pcpness to it I'm speaking
very broadly here then you could maybe
get the solution and correct back so you
now have somehow encoded the end penis
into the problem and you have a sort of
an interesting Quantum state
you can write down this explicit
hamiltonian
um
but we don't need to talk about it
explicitly the only problem
is that this while this hamiltonian is
what's called combinatorial nltius which
is a softer requirement in specific nlts
it doesn't look like it's nlts
that's because we can't seem to prove
lower bounds for it and that's because
morally when the solutions to C
correspond to what's called a collapsing
hash function there exists a
non-wellspread energy state
and a collapsing hash function it's like
it's a cryptographic notion but roughly
speaking what it means is is bqp hard to
distinguish the uniform superposition
over solutions from any single solution
so what you get is that if there was a
low enter if the ground state looked
like this then there was a low energy
state which was just that you took the
ground state and you pruned it to this
orange circle
around it and that was very low energy
which means that the checks in the bulk
like the bulk of the area between the
Peaks don't have much
um weight there's collapsing hash
functions or most hash functions
presumably right okay
so but the real the real issue is that
this hamiltonian we defined it too much
in one basis it was two Z bases
dependent right it was saying I want
this problem as one basis
so the question
is can we do something a little bit
different and I got excited this and I
thought it's worth mentioning this what
I think is a surprising connection to
Quantum money or lightning which is in
the quantum money proposal by xandry he
had this idea that okay there's a hash
function and there's this thing called
the money state and it's it's
proportional to the set of solutions
okay and here's this beautiful theorem
that says hey if H the hash function is
Collision resistant which means given a
solution h x equals s it's hard to find
another solution and non-collapsing then
this is a Quantum lightning scheme I
don't know how to say much about this
but I can say the following thing is
there's sort of two issues
one is if that the solutions of H
inverse of s their distance from each
other is at most l
well then there is an N to the L time
algorithm for finding the next solution
right so it says that at least the
solutions have to be somewhat far apart
in order
um have the Collision resistance
but then
the H is collapsing and any algorithm
that looks like hamiltonian energy
estimation for an L local hamiltonian
seemed hard
uh and so it proves one thing about
Quantum money which just says that look
if you're going to have this your
algorithm has to be very far from a
notion of hamiltonian energy estimation
it can't look like this
right
so there's an intermediate problem which
I think is worth thinking about for both
lightning and PCP which is
take NP problems C1 C2 they could be
equal it doesn't matter and you want to
construct a hamiltonian whose ground
States has sort of the following
measuring statistics which is that in
one picture you can get given a
measurement in that purple region you
can derive the solution X
so that it's a solution to the first
Hamilton uh for to the first CSP
and in each of the you know bubbles you
derive a different solution and the same
thing for the second thing
but there's a key desired property you
need which is that if you measure a
ground state it gives you some entropy
over solutions to either C1 or C2
so either you can right and this is just
because of the The Duality that you
can't be too certain in one picture and
the other
right and you should be thinking it
should this that this picture should
morally really represent you sort of
like uh the codes so in some sense what
we're looking for is something that
looks kind of like coding Theory but is
encoding uh NP problems so we're sort of
trying to look for hypergraph products
of NP problems we know how to take
hypergraph problems of like equations
like ax equals zero right that's how we
form these Quantum codes but I'm asking
for something much stronger which is can
I take the hypergraph product of NP
problems
do this even without the key desired
properties
gcsps and no I don't think so so even
that's fun even that this is I think a
very exciting
um
okay
um if anyone has a name that would be
also helpful how is this different
between coding a record a recording code
of the witness is because you're
assuming that you're imposing that the
C1 of X is you know what so with the
error correction code you viewed at this
but the csps you get just correspond to
code so they're trivial they're like
just linear equations of the type you
know x equals zero okay so there's not
encoding any computational hardness if
you encode equations which are like ax
does not equal zero then like hofstad's
PCP even gives you the like maximizing
problems over those are hard or if you
included quadratic equations right you
can get hardness that way but taking the
hypergraph product of equations that are
not just simple kernels or taking Hyper
products of quadratic equations
I
I I'm not sure what the right notion is
even on whether it's a vacuum object or
not
okay yeah so please if anyone has ideas
for names
okay the next thing I think we could try
is maybe we go back maybe we step back
and say let's think about stronger State
complexity bounds and there's a set of
objects which I think are very
interesting which I called trivially
rotated stabilizer states which is a
very simple idea which is you take a
Clifford circuit and then you allow
yourself to run a consonant circuit on
top these also form a class of State NP
Witnesses but they seem rather strong in
the sense that any State uh of this type
um it doesn't satisfy uh so excuse me
our previous proof of nlts you know can
be broken by such States
right because the Clifford gives you all
the strength because the hamiltonian we
have an nlts is stabilizer so it's
ground States or Clifford States so this
gives you all the strength you need so
thinking about this conjecture might
force a new method of proving lower
bounds for Quantum states which then
resets the whole clock right because
then we get to start from the beginning
and we don't hit these kind of apparent
contradictions
um the other thing is there you know I
should mention there were um
some really nice conjectures one called
the nlss by
um carabin and legal uh and then you
know this proof that there is a state
that's simultaneously not stabilizer and
um
uh no low energy sampleable states I
think
um but it really was sort of asking for
a specific State and a lower bound
um and that's something that's worth you
know
crying
um or I think you know you go back and
say something about how
uh Quantum pcps are you know try to
provably show M A hardness bqp hardness
BPP hardness like you know trying but
there are natural barriers in that
direction
I mean in in one definition at least if
one PCP is trivially to keep you hard I
mean not that definition
if it's trivial it's not the other
definition
I mean the definition of data
amplification versus the definition of
probabilistic accessibility to truth and
it for both the accessibility to the
truth then it's trivial because
equivalent
okay okay
exactly so so right so that's why you
know these even showing BPP hardness
right you have to choose the right
reduction for the problem to be
interesting
okay
um last thing I'll say is that you know
you might say okay well you know the
classical PCP theorem was inherently
based on error correction
so maybe I need to just apply Quantum
error correction to a ground state of a
hamiltonian and you know sort of massage
my way up right but there's a problem
with Quantum error correction codes
which is a very simple folklore theorem
of local and distinguishability which
says that the small reduced density
matrices of codes are invariants of the
encoded state where D is the distance of
the code it's a very simple proof and it
also plugs that no cloning theorem issue
right in the heart of it so no cloning
rate just says that this sort of
transformation is non-linear Quantum
error correction would say well okay if
you have an error let's say these red
qubits
um
if it's a correctable Erasure error then
what that means is that you know you
could remove those qubits out and then
given the state remaining with the whole
you could regenerate those qubits but
now you have two copies of that you know
the state that was there so the only
reconciliation of this that you've
apparently saw done some uh Quantum
cloning is that the the reduced density
Matrix
on that small region was completely
determined by the code it doesn't
actually contain any information you
could have just generated those that
reduce density Matrix state for free
by yourself
right so it tells you that there's no
information in these uh local regions
so why does that have an issue well you
know I'm paraphrasing I'm trying to be
as general as possible like if you're in
the elevator and you have to explain to
someone the PCP theorem you could you
would say that it's you know you apply
an elegant locally testable code around
a satisfying assignment or formula that
would be you know like a five second
description but you can't do the same
thing for Quantum pcps because if you
used a code with distance D then in
order for the local hamiltonian to be
able to distinguish yes and no instances
it has to have a locality bigger than D
but if we're looking for constant
locality hamiltonians then you're using
a very very weak code in the first place
so why did you use the code at all right
did you gain anything from using it
probably not
um
yeah and I think that's the last thing
I'm going to say
[Applause]
what happens
ah um you mean can you prove uh
so for one if you think of a non-local
HomeTown non-constant locality
hamiltonian and LTS is Trivial yeah
um
but it's even open I think if log local
hamiltonians you can prove the quantum
PCB produced
we tried at one point remember with
perturbation gadgets unsuccessfully
to even get lost but yeah
any other questions
it's a bit about local decodability like
this question
hey it just says that like if you would
if everything was wrapped in a code like
you knew the solution would have code
state so there was no real information
hiding in the small
um measurements right so the idea is
that if there is a Quantum PC conjecture
the reduced density matrices themselves
even though they're small they carry a
lot of information right
principally it tells you that you know
if there was a Quantum PSP conjecture
the local reduced density of matrices do
not look like maximum mixed States right
because if they all look like maximum
state in the maximum Nick state is a
solution right so that tells you that
some of the reduced density matrices
have to be far from maximally mixed and
codes for example the reduced density
matrices are basically maximized
okay you mentioned the news that there
are some examples of circuit that
developments of corner states that don't
look like they said there was like some
very specifications
yeah so um there one example that
Natalie and I worked out uh earlier this
week is you know if you wanted to prove
that there was a phase state that was
far from Clippers so the Clifford States
really look like fade states with
quadratic phases phases are defined by
quadratic function so if you take a
higher degree polynomial not too high
like a degree five or something
polynomial you can show this very far
from all of these Clifford States right
so you can come up with
um lower bounds than that and that seems
very different
temperatures
for robustness
if there's a gamma function we have
[Applause]
foreign